[Applause]
our next speaker is a incredibly isn't
incredibly experienced linguist working
at a lab at MIT with a small group of
researchers and through studying our
language and the way that we communicate
with other people
he has stumbled upon the secret of human
intimacy here to give us his perspective
please welcome to the stage anthony
banette cially
[Applause]
you might think I know what you're going
through you might be looking at me here
on the red dots or you might be looking
at me on the screen there's a 1/6 of a
second delay did I catch myself I did I
could see myself before I turned and
that small delay creates a little bit of
a divide
and a divide is exactly what happens
with human language and the processing
of that language I of course am working
out of a small lab at MIT and we are
scraping for every insight that we can
get this is not often associated with a
computational challenge but in this case
we found that that persistence of vision
and auditory intake actually have more
in common than we ever realized and we
can see it in this first slide
[Applause]
immediately your processing goes to is
that a hard-boiled egg is that perhaps
the structural integrity of the egg
being able to sustain the weight of what
seems to be Iraq aha
is it in fact a real rock we go to
questions when we see visual information
but when we hear information this is
what happens the floodgates in our mind
open much like the streets of Shanghai
so many pieces of information to process
so many ideas concepts feelings and of
course vulnerabilities that we don't
often wish to share and so we hide and
we hide behind what we like to call the
floodgate of intimacy and what might
that floodgates be holding what is the
dike upon which it is built well first
off
[Applause]
we found that it's different for six
different genotypes
and of course we can start categorizing
these genotypes into a neuro normative
experience and a neurodiverse experience
on the right-hand side of the screen
you're seeing spikes for the
neuro-diverse thinking now there are
generally only two emotional states that
a neurodiverse brain can tabulate and
keep count of at any given time thereby
eliminating the possibility for them to
be emotionally sometimes attune to the
present situation but on the left hand
side you can see the neuro normative
brain which can often handle about five
different pieces of emotional cognitive
information at any given time these are
this slight variances that you are
seeing in the 75 90 and 60 percentile
and then of course that dramatic
difference of the 25 40 and 35
percentile but of course what is the
neural network that is helping to bridge
and build these difference discrepancies
[Applause]
fear
and as we all know fear resides in the
amygdala and is a very natural response
and it is very closely linked with
visual perception it is not as closely
linked with verbal perception so our
fear receptors often will be going off
in advance of any of our cognitive usage
around verbal and words and cues of
language so as we see these fear moments
we of course are taken aback we stumble
in a certain direction
generally away from the intimacy now of
course there is a difference between the
male perception and the female
perception and of trans and those who
are in between all of those as well and
outside of the gender spectrum but fear
is the central underlying underpinning
of all of our response systems
fight-or-flight is the one of the most
earliest some say reptilian response to
our environments how can we disengage or
unhook ourselves from the horns of the
amygdala well I'd like to tell you the
secret right now
[Applause]
this is all making much much too much
sense the secret lies in turning our
backs to one another and I know that
that sounds absolutely like the opposite
of what you were expecting but when in a
relationship you turn your back to your
partner and place your back upon their
back you eliminate visual cues you are
more readily available to failing first
and failing first far outweighs the
lengths we go to to appeal to others to
our partners and to ourselves we spend
billions and billions of dollars on
clothing on makeup on the latest trend
of glasses but what we don't spend money
and time on is connecting with each
other in a way that is truthful and
honest and strips of those visual
receptors
it sounds hard doesn't it
[Applause]
but we want to be aggressive about this
we don't want to just sit on the couch
as a historian said earlier today it's
important to get up and circumvent
sometimes that couch and how can we do
it
well yes ice is a big part of it
insights compassion and empathy
I see II
and when we start using this ice method
well
the possibilities become much bigger
than us
in fact they become smaller than you on
a molecular level I believe that that
insight is the unifying theme for every
talk you have seen so far at Ted and
will continue as we of course embark on
this journey here on this tiny planet on
the ledge on the precipice as we are
seeing yes death is inevitable will it
meet all of us at the same time I think
is the variable that we are inquiring
I think that timeline gets a bit longer
when we use ice and when we rest our
backs upon one another and build
together leaving behind the fear and
working towards they'll edit this part
out a ripened experience of love
compassion intimacy based on a truth
that you are sharing from your mind's
eye and the heart that we all can touch
tactile II feel have maybe potentially a
mushy experience that we don't just
throw out because it is browned what led
us slice in half the experience we have
gathered let us see what the heart the
core the seed of that idea in each of us
is and let us share it back to back
thank you very much
[Applause]